trailing other developed nations and
many of its asian neighbors by many
weeks
finally japan is rolling out its
vaccines
the first people to get the fisa jab are
thousands of health workers
often criticized for failing to use the
latest technology
in controlling the outbreak japan is now
using a popular online messaging service
to centralize the vaccination booking
system
but a lack of specialized syringes means
millions
of doses could be wasted
since the vaccines are very valuable the
government is working to procure more
special syringes
that can extract six doses from each
vial
contributing to the delayed rollout has
been the requirement for extensive
testing of the vaccine
in a country that historically has a
mistrust
of mass vaccination campaigns
the vaccine was developed so quickly so
it scares me to think about its side
effects
and its effectiveness i have no concerns
but i get vaccinated when it becomes
available japan has imposed strict
border controls which it believes has
helped in keeping the outbreak under
control
so many here are worried about the
prospect of hosting the upcoming summer
olympics
so opening up the borders and bringing
people from all over the world
where there are various different
strains of the virus
does not seem like an inspired idea to a
lot of public
health officials and to the public at
large
but the government is determined they
will go ahead at the end of july
although big questions remain over what
form
they will take last year the government
was
also determined right up until they
pulled the plug
so i think you know sometime later in
march
uh we'll have a better idea if they are
going to proceed
uh but you know really the olympics has
lurched from one crisis to another
scandal
the latest scandal has been the
resignation of former olympic committee
president
yashiro mori over sexist remarks he made
earlier this month
the government is hoping a successful
vaccination campaign
can help turn around the fortunes of its
ill-fated games
rob mcbride al jazeera